Now that we understand the distributed object model
of Java and how to build services using
the distributed Java object model and publish it
and make it accessible to the clients. let's look
at how the RMI is actually implemented? At
the core of the RMI implementation is this layer
called Remote Reference Layer, RRL. And that's the
place where a lot of magic happens. The client
site stub, is going to initiate a
remote method invocation call using this Remote
Reference Layer, and all of the magic
with respect to marshaling the arguments. In
order to send it over the network and so on is handled entirely by
this Remote Reference Layer. And similarly when
the result comes back unmarshaling the results
into the data structures, that the client understands is once
again accomplished using this RRL layer. On the server side. The
skeleton that exists is therefore unmarshaling the
arguments that comes from the client. And
in order to unmarshal the argument, the
skeleton uses a Remote Reference Layer, because
a Remote Reference Layer knows how to unmarshal
the arguments that are coming in. And the the
skeleton then makes the call up to the server
that is implementing the remote object. Once the server
is done with the service, the skeleton marshals the
result, and once again goes through the Remote Reference
Layer to send it over to the client. And
when it comes back, the Remote Reference Layer and
the stub work together to deliver the results in
a digestible format to the client. So, marshaling and unmarshaling,
they're also called serializing and deserialization in the Java world.
Marshaling and unmarshaling are also called. Serializing and
deserializing Java objects, and all of that is being
done by the RRL layer. So basically, the objects that
are being passed this arguments, they are
serialized by the RRL, and deserialized. On the
server end, and given to the server. And similarly, the result, which is also an
object, is serialized using the Remote Reference
Layer. And when it arrives on the client
side, it is deserialized, and delivered as
a result object back up to the client.
Now where are the clients and the servers? Are
they on the same machine, on a different machine?
Of course we're talking about networked services, and, so
the server's going to be remote. But the server could
have several instances. There could be a single instance
of a server, or there could be multiple instances
of the server and the server may have ability
for doing persistence and so on. Where is all that
magic happening? Well, similar to the subcontract layer
that we discussed in the spring system, the Remote
Reference Layer is doing all the magic with
respect to. Where the server is? How the server
is handling request? Is it replicated? Is it
a singleton server? All of these things are being
handled through the Remote Reference Layer. So what
that means is it allows for various invocation protocols
between the client and the servers. And all of those things are buried in the
Remote Reference Layer. And the actual clients and
the servers can be impervious to those details.
So, the Java run time stack, the RRL layer is a very crucial layer. And it
has functionalities very similar to the subcontract mechanism
and the spring system. And as I mentioned
earlier Java RMI derives a lot from the subcontract mechanism.
And, so there is not much surprise that there are
similarities between the RRL layer and the subcontract mechanism. Having
discussed RRL, let's go and talk about, the transport layer.